shared that they are not going to
enforce state and federal gun laws they
have decided that they are going to
essentially refuse to implement laws
that are on the books that is a growing
problem in this country and I think
we're gonna have to have a conversation
about that in the United States Senate
do we want to continue to supply funding
to law enforcement in counties that
refuse to implement state and federal
gun laws sorry Chris Americans aren't
giving up their guns that easily in fact
Santa is going to be packing heat this
Christmas gun sales are booming with the
FBI running nearly 200 000 background
checks for Black Friday and the number
of handgun owners carrying daily in the
United States has doubled in four years
what Senator Chris Murphy talking about
here nothing let me tell you what's
wrong with Senator Chris Murphy here
what he says that he wants a defund
police departments that aren't making
arrests on Gunner gun crimes first of
all how do you decide whether or not the
police should make an arrest is it
whether or not not there is sufficient
evidence who decides whether there's
sufficient evidence what if the
prosecutor says there isn't sufficient
evidence what if there isn't a
conviction what if the case isn't
cleared they haven't investigated let's
go to the prosecutors what if the
prosecutors like Alvin Bragg decide
we're not even going to prosecute an
arrest so don't even bother to make an
arrest for a gun crime and you want to
talk about Sanctuary let's talk about
Sanctuary cities where illegals who end
up committing crimes are protected from
law enforcement and they're not
prosecuted for crimes you wanted to fund
law enforcement how about you to fund
the FBI they knew about Nicholas Cruz in
the Parkland shooting they knew about
the tsarnia brothers they were warned by
Russia twice and while you're at it what
about the fact that in all of these
jurisdictions gun crimes may not be the
priority that murders are for example
and you've defunded everybody already so
they don't have half of the resources
they need for these crimes and let me
tell you one more thing he's facing this
whole thing on the 2021 situation where
the LGBT
2-1 whatever shooter uh had a problem
with his mother he says and had they
done a red flag on this kid this this
shooting at the lgbtq club would have
happened you're wrong and I'll tell you
why it was more than a year ago and that
means it would have expired wow Chris
Murphy just got hit in the face
what do you have to say about that that
makes a lot of sense can't argue with it
well then I guess I have nothing to say
that way what you're looking for
so the judge is obviously right about
the expiration on the report of the bomb
threat to his mother but it turns out as
well that in 2015 he had an incident
when he went to live with his
grandparents in San Antonio there was
some online bullying
um and he had lashed out and that was
something that could have been reported
but it wasn't and what Chris Murphy is
talking about is that if there are
communities and this was the first
County after Jared Polis signed the red
flag law in 2019 to say we don't want to
be a part of this that if you don't want
to be a part of it that you shouldn't
get the same level of funding as people
who want to enforce the laws that are on
the books and now in the wake of the
Uvalde shooter shooting if you see how
many Republicans are for red flag laws
this should be updated I don't know if
these policies should exist and maybe we
should have a longer terms on these red
flag law reportings it should be longer
than a year should Alvin Bragg's office
be defunded because he's come right out
and said I'm not going to prosecute this
this
Sanctuary cities run by democrats
whether it's the governor or local
person so we're not going to arrest on
this this this and this crime let's just
do it across the board
sure well said Judge Jeanine you are on
fire right now Dana just besides the
obvious
lack of common sense that this makes
what about politically you have a
Democrat Senator just stepping in the
defund goo all over so if you want to
make your gun control policies popular
or be persuasive with them you shouldn't
tie them to the defund the police
movement that's what all the Democrats
were talking about as they were facing
tougher races than they wanted to in in
the midterms but that's going back all
four years ago remember the defund the
police was a big problem for them in
2020 as well as when Republicans picked
up seats and also we the the Congress
just passed gun control legislation
this past summer
and it didn't stop the shootings now it
might help prevent some in the future
which would be good but if you want to
have more laws you have to be honest
about the fact that you just passed one
that didn't work why would this be
different and you cannot tie it to
defund the police or else you're going
to end up one even more unpopular but
two what you said Jesse that people are
buying guns but those people are buying
them legally and that a lot of these
some of these shooters are buying them
legally so where where's that can I
think you could find consensus
bipartisan consensus that says okay
those types of people should not get
guns how do you do that and I'm not I'm
not an expert in that but I think that's
where the you could pinpoint the problem
and people are asking Santa Claus for
weapons this Christmas wow
hmm that's an interesting way to get a
gun
yep
enforcing laws until the Dems decided to
stop punishing the violators that's the
problem I think he was trying to do what
the you know the Liberals to steal from
the left they were trying to own the
cons by adopting the sanctuary language
to guns because he thought that would be
clever but the analogy is lousy because
there is no Sanctuary for breaking gun
laws the way there is sanctuary for
breaking immigration laws uh so it's
like the so that's why it's so confusing
because it sounded like he was saying
I'm going to defund the police even if
the police are doing their job and you
legally own a gun that's what it sounds
like but having said that I love the
idea of a sanctuary City for guns or
just a sanctuary neighborhood because
what a great experiment to take eight
blocks of Manhattan everybody there can
legally own and carry as long as they're
law-abiding citizens they're not
criminals what a great experiment that
would be to see what would happen in
those eight square blocks compared to
the rest of the city everybody would
want to live there to everybody but the
thing is I never do the experiment
because they'll know no one wants to
know the outcome it's like you know when
the movies and the mob movies nobody
commits a crime in a mob neighborhood
yeah yeah it's also but they'll do
experiments of legalizing
um like opium dens yes in the middle of
San Francisco
uh where were those opium guns again
okay
Donnie spoke me a flight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else